I
okay I think we can get started we'll
come back everybody our next speaker is
cavallino with male and undertakes I
think more more MORE okay even more
interesting yes welcome and thank you so
hello everyone my name is Carolyn Alex
you and I am going to present to you a
project that I did in my company
paralytics based in Zurich and which is
still ongoing so as a company what we do
is that we analyze big data from telco
companies and we provide the insights to
other companies or governments we have a
growing team of engineers statisticians
and data scientists and customers all
over the world and our slogan is that we
get signal and we transform it to
information and subsequently to value
for our customers so I said that we use
a data from telco companies I would like
to show you a video which shows what
this data looks like so these needles
sorry Carly not coming could you please
take the mic and so again I the green
dots it's green tote is a subscriber
moving in the area of Hong Kong in
February 19 and red areas are areas
where there are a lot of subscribers as
you can see from from this data it is
not really possible to see what the
individual is doing but we're not
interested in that we are interested in
the trends and the trends so that there
are some people some locations that are
very popular and you can also see the
bridges of hong kong by those traces of
people moving on them it is a data from
a cell phone events so every time you
sent a methods then event is generated
but we don't use CDR data you mean a
call records right we don't use we don't
have access to this so we transform this
data this very low data into an
analytics platform for a mall operators
all over the world and i'm going to show
Adam of our dashboard as well
so here we choose a date to look at
what's happening in a particular model
in Singapore and here the graph shows
how many people there are in the mall in
to our buckets and this is a thursday we
can compare it with the next friday and
we can see that the traffic is quite
different in the afternoon people are
more likely to visit and we can also saw
demographics about what people visit
what kind of people visit them all so we
don't have that many people aged the 55
to 59 we have a lot of young people yes
we we do that and we also account for
biases for instance as some people some
categories of people use their phone
more often so we account for that to
correct so yeah I the video just sold
the percentage of males and females
there are a bit more females in the mall
in fact in a row data we saw some more
males but we adjusted for the visibility
bias and then we got data that is more
correct another thing we saw is say
where people were three hours before and
three hours after visiting the mold so
the mall is here and the most of the
people we're around this area three
hours before so okay that's
not very big surprise the same situation
for for three hours after I perhaps a
more interesting graph is the map that
shows where people come from to this
mall so people do come from the very
neighborly riya to the mall but they
also come from this location so using a
local knowledge we learned that this
location is actually a very densely
populated area of Singapore and actually
all those cells that are red are across
a train line so we can make hypotheses
that people people do not mind using the
train to go and soap at this particular
mode
so I would like to talk about the
architecture of our project and we're
Python comes into it so we make heavy
use of the Hadoop ecosystem after
getting the data from our telco partners
we store it on Nate's DFS we compress
them and force schema using apache avro
and for sanity sex cleaning taking we
query the data with peak or hive we also
use MapReduce in Java a lot to do very
heavy duty tasks such as group by and
filtering relevant events in the stream
so the topless that we get can't be
thought of as just records with one time
stamp and fuzzy location ID of course we
don't have quite the same amount of
accuracy in location as GPS coordinates
and they anonymized user IDs so after we
have transformed our data into smaller
medium sized datasets I would say we do
a transformation so these and we make
heavy use of the pandas library for
instance say all the mall visits in a
mall can be stored in in one pan tostado
frame and we also use multiple lead to
to do some quick plotting and ultimately
we produce CSV data to populate to
populate the dashboard that I just so so
I would like to get a bit deeper into
the path of stuff so I have created the
repo or Nikita hub where you can they
follow the code that I'm gonna show so
I'm going to wait for a
a few minutes so that everyone who's
interested can my clone my github pepper
you want the URL again yep there cuddle
linux / by data
okay so let's get started so i'm
importing several things in the
beginning so first of all they as i said
before upload data requires a schema to
function so I'm gonna use a the Python
avril library to to parse the schema so
that everybody can be aware of what type
of records we're going to look at so
this is the schema it has a user ID a
start which is a long it is a timestamp
an end and again a field that tells us
whether the visitor is a repeat visitor
or not so this data has already been
processed from the rotel codata
otherwise I would not be able to share
it with you and the schema has been
generated by a really nice tool by
Cloudera which can take a CSV file and
create a schema
so now we can open our sample file and
print out some metadata about it so you
actually can you see the code or should
i zoom in the letters better so as you
can see the a profile has been
compressed with the with using snappy
which is a google compression scheme and
now we will use the Avro reader to
create a list of a records and we can
also see if the schema matches the
records that we got I'm just going to do
it for the last one yes it does so I
would like to note here that i am using
the Avro library for python a for the
sake of the example in reality it is
there is a much faster library called
fast at Avro with faster and but it
doesn't support the snappy compression
so it there needs to be some work done
before it can be a perfect for us so now
i'm going to create a data frame from
this list of records which is pretty
straightforward and now you can see the
first five records of the data frame so
let's describe this so they user ID 922
whatever I went to the mall at this time
then left at this time and it was the
first time we saw them visiting Lee
small
now I would like to transform those time
stops into a more readable format so i
will use date time UTC from time stamp
and also apply the hour of set for
singapore which is eight hours so now we
can see that we have data from the 18th
of februari to the 21st of februari so i
only want to look at one day so i'm
going to filter the rest out with pandas
selectors and now let's do some data
analysis i would like to to see how
people arrive and how people leave the
mall so if you remember that they move
that i sold this is quite similar we see
two peaks in the day we see one peak at
lunchtime and one pick up at the
afternoon and the departures follow a
similar pattern so how did I group by in
my time I used a nice utility of pandas
the time grouper which can group by any
time interval and if I wanted to have a
bit less noisy results I could group by
30 minutes and as you can see the curve
becomes smoother and you can see the
trend more easily so now I want to
further process this information and see
if I can get some business insights
outlets so one idea is to see if
visitors that have visited the mall
before arrive with a different partner
than regular visitors it does not look
like that this is happening but the good
thing about using Python for this sort
of thing is that you can quickly take
hypothesis like this now the first the
blue line is ray all the visits well I
could also plot with how the first line
be I will make the first line being
known a repeating visitors first time
wasters
okay so yeah one could say that there is
a slight difference it seems like that
non repeat visitors come a bit more
often at lunch time but it's hard to
verify whether this is right now whether
this is an artifact or a real real
insight but thanks for the suggestion so
I'm gonna try something else I'm going
to observe the behavior of return
visitors with respect to how much they
stay so I'm going to look at their
duration in minutes and then I'm going
to find the median visit duration of all
visitors of returning visitors and of
first-time visitors so as you can see
the median visit duration of returning
visitors is it's quite longer
significantly longer than they want to
first-time visitors and in order to be
solved that this is a statistically
valid and significant I'm going to do a
t-test for for the two samples one being
the visit durations of people who come
for the first time and the other being
the visit durations of people who come
for a second or third time so and if the
p-value of this test is close to zero
that means that the means of the two
samples are significantly different and
as you can see the p-value is very very
small so that validates our insight
about repeat visitors spending a lot
more time in the mode so that means that
the mall operators can benefit from
these knowledge and
evaluate differently there are the
different sets of visitors because
obviously visitors come for a second
time are more loyal to them and they
probably them also think about how to go
about getting visitors to come again so
as somebody mentioned in the beginning
we don't actually have information about
all the people that are in the mall and
that happens for several reasons the
first one is that we only have contracts
with one telco per country or possibly
more but we don't have every user with a
cellphone another reason is that people
don't use their cell phone all the time
so somebody may very well visit them all
I'd never generate any events so what we
do is that we collect ground truth on
site and then we compare these numbers
to owls and extrapolate we are using our
and the psychic learn and we're also at
the moment looking for a social
scientist to do this better not only a
use mathematical tools like regression
but also insight on all people behave
people's behavior so now I would like to
say a few things about how this this
project evolved from the ground up so
the first version was basically a folder
full of ipython notebooks and I
personally went on site in a mall to
count people myself to verify our
numbers and the output was just some
matplotlib plots and the spreadsheet
with counts was not Matt's was not as
pretty as the dust for
that I sold but it got our foot in the
door of course it was just a proof of
concept and since it was basically some
scattered ipython notebooks didn't have
a clear workflow I which is why we
quickly decided to refactor this we
defined some sort of workflow which was
split in two parts the first part was
the MapReduce which would do the heavy
lifting of filtering out people that had
events close to the mall which already
filtered out allow a large percentage of
the data and then transform it into a
format similar as the Avro file that I
sold and then we did etl with a 1 Python
script that read from the MapReduce
output and also thankfully we managed to
outsource ground-truth collection and we
hide the statistician to improve our
correlation techniques we also added new
features they want that I showed on the
dashboard where people come to come from
and go to we will also provide it with
demographics from some of the
subscribers so we were able to break
down the behavior of customers by their
different demographics and we deployed
it successfully on customer service
however some issues still remain the
workflow is not perfect it sometimes
requires manual intervention and manual
restarts if something fails and also as
much as we all like pantis data frames
they are not a sufficient abstraction
for the problem that we have we need to
do something more and also we are always
on the lookout for a creating different
insights that are more attractive to our
customers so
oh this is a work in progress but one
way that I figured we could pass up our
workflow is to use Luigi and then store
intermediate results and we would need
to start the whole thing from the
beginning if something fails so we are
right now trying to integrate Luigi into
our product so basically they're in this
workflow in two separate Luigi tasks for
those of you who don't know what Luigi's
it is a work flow monitoring Python who
is particularly suited to us because it
accounts for it has already pre-made sub
configurations for Java MapReduce jobs
or scholar and spark jobs which we also
use in the company so the plan now is to
create higher level abstractions on data
frames perhaps wrappers around them and
use domain specific classes to model for
instance a user or a mole visit and as I
said it's a work in progress so thank
you for listening and if you would like
to learn more you can email us at
recruiting dr. latex dotnet and I'm just
saying one one way to to get our
attention would be to fork the repo I
sold and show us what you can do with
the data thank you very much
are there any questions ya can tell us
something about the accuracy of
pinpointing people down on the ground
what can you tell something about
accuracy so how what what's the the
let's say the prayer the perimeter that
you can track an individual down yes so
we generally get information about what
cell the person was connected to and
then the granularity of the cells varies
a bit depending on where we are in an
urban setting there might be two or
three cells in a particular building in
a rural setting it might be just one
cell that is serving a whole valley or a
village so but with respect to moles we
generally target moles that are big
enough to have indoor cells which means
that somebody who connects to the cell
cannot currently must be in the building
and you cannot generally connect from
outside so that is that improves our
accuracy further questions it's not the
case and thanks again
you
you